be patient is a very hard thing to
operationalize so whenever you're doing
anything you're fundamentally being
patient for everything else that you're
not doing as long as you have a plan of
what you're going to do in the meantime
you are patient for everything else that
you quote want to be patient for no
one's going to just sit there with their
hands and be like I'm being patient no
the marshmallow test for kids when they
looked at what the kids were doing that
were able to wait for the second
marshmallow most of them distracted
themselves they either took the
marshmallow put it in their pocket they
started like singing songs to themselves
doing things in the meantime whereas the
kids who couldn't resist it just sat
there and stared at the marshmallow
until eventually they broke and so what
happened is instead of using willpower
they just ignored it and kept themselves
occupied that's the key skill is
figuring out what you're going to do in
the meantime not trying to think I'm
impatient it's just you haven't figured
out what your alternative plan is